how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we finally have the spider-man far from
home trailer and it was an amazing
trailer still just a teaser trailer but
nonetheless amazing and this is
technically the first trailer for phase
4 of the MCU so it's really exciting
there's a lot to talk about a lot to
break down and some Easter eggs as well
and some tiny tiny hints at Avengers
endgame now it's not mentioned at all in
the trailer nor are the events of
Avengers infinity war but that was
expected they're not going to give
anything away about Avengers in game in
this trailer so let's just jump right
into it so the first scene we have is
spider-man and Aunt May at an event
supporting the homeless so if you
remember the last scene for spider-man
homecoming Aunt May now knows that Peter
is spider-man and it looks like she
accepted it pretty well and actually
looks pretty excited about it enough for
her to go to events with him and
high-five him after at least so then we
have happy Hogan coming after and this
is where we see the romance between him
and Aunt May there was talk about a
romance between happy and Aunt May after
the trailer was shown at sea cxp in
South Paulo Brazil and now we're finally
seeing it on screen and it's very
noticeable they're doing it on purpose
obviously showing the Bears of romance
between them and Peter is kind of like
what the heck is going on because he can
tell - so in the next scene you see
Peter Parker packing and he says that
he's going to Europe on a school trip so
this is obviously setting up the fact
that he's going to be far from home he's
not gonna be in New York he's going to
be in Europe but in this next scene is
something really really interesting we
see spider-man swinging around in the
city and in the back is the old avengers
tower so in spider-man homecoming we
learned that Tony Stark actually sold
the old Avengers Tower and the Avengers
headquarters moved to upstate New York
well as you can see in this still
somebody has already bought the building
and has begun renovations on it since
the trailer showed at CC XP there has
been talk and rumors that this could be
a fantastic for building or a Norman
Osborn building out of the - it's more
than likely a Norman Osborn building we
haven't seen him in the MCU and he's a
huge part of spider-man and at the time
that this was filming and still
currently did
and marvel do not own the rights to use
the Fantastic Four in the MCU so it's
more than likely an Osborn building so
the next scene shows Peter Parker going
to pick up a passport and this is
actually a really cool Easter Egg if you
notice his date of birth on the passport
says August 10th that's actually the
date that Spiderman appeared for the
very first time in the comics August of
1962 so that's a cool little easter egg
they did there so the next scene is a
pretty big scene he's trying to pack for
his trip and Aunt May tells him to pack
his spider-man suit but he doesn't want
to pack his spider-man suit we hear him
say I just want to go on a trip with my
friends so he doesn't want to go with
spider-man he wants to go as Peter
Parker he kind of wants to put down that
mantle just for a little bit so he can
enjoy this vacation with his friends and
he even says that Europe doesn't need a
friendly neighborhood spider-man but
another big thing about this scene is
that if you look at his spider-man suit
this is not the iron spider suit so he
doesn't have the iron spider suit for
some reason Kevin Feige has already come
out and said that this movie is not a
prequel to infinity war or Avengers end
game so that leaves us with the question
why doesn't he have his iron spider suit
why does he have his old suit this is
obviously something that we probably
won't figure out until after avengers
end game has come out in theaters and
then there's a really cool Easter Egg
where we see Peter close his suitcase
you can tell that his suitcase is pretty
old it looks pretty beat up but on it
has the initials BFP the initials stand
for
Ben F Parker which of course is Uncle
Ben so this is his Uncle Ben's suitcase
that he now has then we have a few
scenes that show him actually going to
Europe and this is where we see the
romance start between him and MJ and if
you notice they actually all call her MJ
now it's a pretty funny scene they show
the awkwardness of Peter Parker trying
to flirt with MJ here and she's just
messing with him but ultimately you can
tell that they both like each other and
this is the start of a romance and we
can hear Peter talking to Ned about that
in the next scene in their hotel room
where he says I just want to spend some
time with MJ I think she really likes me
dude and then BAM
Ned gets hit in the neck with a tranq
Dart from Nick Fury knocking him out
so I've already seen some people
wondering why didn't Peter spidey senses
go off and tell him that Nick Fury was
in his room because as you can see this
takes him by total surprise but yes he
does have spidey senses we saw
this and Avengers infinity war but they
did not go off because Nick Fury is not
a threat to him just like in spider-man
homecoming where his spidey senses then
and go off when Ned was in his room Ned
was not a threat to him and Nick Fury is
not a threat to him so his spidey senses
did not go off then Nick Fury introduces
himself in true Nick Fury fashion super
spy super cool super casual gist nice to
finally meet you spider-man Peter
instantly recognizes that it's Nick Fury
and although he has never met him before
he does know who he is because of his
involvement with Iron Man and happy also
kind of funny to see Nick Fury alive
because the last time we saw him he was
turning to dust again they're not going
to give anything about Avengers end game
away in this trailer but Nick Fury
clearly comes back somehow so Nick Fury
tells him to put some clothes on let's
go for a ride and this is where he
recruits spider-man for a mission
we then see Peter with the spider-man
suit on in a boat with Nick Fury he
actually did bring his spider-man suit
they showed that to us in the
International trailer so he brought his
original suit but Nick Fury does still
give him new suits and we see that in
the very next scene where he's actually
wearing his red and black suit and it is
actually a glider which is super cool
it's really awesome to see them bring
that into this movie and as you can see
he's using the suit to fly towards this
chaos and destruction that is happening
on this bridge in London we learned that
this chaos and destruction is actually
the elementals attacking the elementals
are extra-dimensional humanoids who
basically have control over the elements
of the earth and the comics there are
four of them hydron who is the Lord of
the waters Magnum who is the master of
the earth hellfire who is the wielder of
flame and Zephyr who is the mistress of
the winds so we hear Nick Fury tell
Peter that he's got gifts but he's got a
job to do and that job is to take out
the elementals and we actually see all
of the elementals throughout the trailer
in the scene we actually see Nick Fury
and Maria Hill fighting Magnum then we
go back to the bridge scene where
there's a lot of chaos going on and we
see lightning and we see fire and the
lightning is most likely Zephyr and the
fire is Hellfire we have another cool
scene that shows spider-man using his
glider suit to fly into the fire most
likely going to fight Hellfire which we
see very briefly in this still right
here and then we have a very interesting
scene with happy
happiest talking to Peter and he says
you're all alone your friends are in
trouble what are you going to do about
it if you want to avoid any Avengers and
game possible spoilers at all skip ahead
like 25 seconds why is happy telling
Peter you are all alone and why does
Nick Fury talk to spider-man directly
and we have not seen Tony Stark at all
in this trailer that could say something
about the events of Avengers in game now
obviously if he is in spider-man far
from home they're not gonna show him in
this trailer they're not going to give
anything away about Avengers in game but
just think about that
we then see spider-man drop in with a
new all-black suit what this is is his
stealth suit this isn't something that
Peter already had this is something that
Nick Fury gave to him we know this
because we have already seen leaked
photos and a leaked video of Peter
Parker in the spider-man stealth suit we
know this because in the leaked photos
we saw on spider-man's upper part of his
chest a shield logo and what's actually
very interesting about this shot and the
trailer is they actually blacked out the
logo not really a big surprise here
Marvel has been known to do this they've
been known to change and tweak a little
bit of the trailers to try to avoid any
spoilers that they can but the stealth
suit is basically exactly what it sounds
like
it helps Peter Parker be stealthy and go
about his business undetected the suit
sort of adapts to the environment
surrounding it and it also helps him see
at night we then go to a scene where
there is an attack from the water
elemental they haven't actually named
the elementals yet they could be going
with the original names or this could
actually be a version of hydro-man this
elemental attacks and we see Peter
Parker trying to help his friends and
everybody else get to safety then we see
the elemental just deliver a huge punch
to Peter Parker knocking him down and
you can tell that he's just very taken
back by how strong this elemental is and
then we have what I think is just the
very best part of the whole entire
trailer Mysterio shows up he makes an
epic drop in then it cuts to Peter
Parker hanging off the edge of a
building soaking wet and then Mysterio
says you don't want any part of this and
then begins to attack the water
elemental we see the beams come out of
his hands and then we see him fly and go
fight the water elemental so Mysterio is
actually a person named Quentin Beck and
Quinton Beck does not have any
superhuman powers
at all but he is very very skilled and
talented he is an expert designer of
special effect devices and stage
illusions a master hypnotist and
magician and a chemist and roboticist so
he can create devices such as his suit
that allow him to fly and create smoke
and if you look at his suit it actually
looks like Chitauri Tech this is the
same tech that vulture from spider-man
homecoming was collecting so it's
possible that he got this tech from
vulture we know that Michael Keaton is
going to be in this movie as vulture
so maybe Mysterio got this tech from
vulture or maybe Peter Parker will have
to work with vulture somehow to take
down Mysterio because although this
trailer does depict Mysterio as a good
guy he is actually the villain and the
comics Mysterio actually wants to be a
hero he wants to be an Avenger so his
plan is to defeat spider-man and show
everybody that he's a better hero and
what Mysterio does is create illusions
and that is probably what the elementals
are in spider-man far from home we
learned from Jake Gyllenhaal himself at
CC XP that Mysterio gets recruited by
Nick Fury he gets recruited by Nick Fury
because he is supposed to be an expert
on these elementals but the reason he's
an expert on them is because he actually
is creating them they are his illusions
and his plan is to make it look like
he's actually a hero and a friend of
spider-man and then defeat spider-man
and again he looks awesome we even get
to see him where his fishbowl helmet I
think the character is done amazingly I
think Jake Gyllenhaal is a perfect actor
to play Mysterio and overall this is
just a phenomenal trailer the next
trailer will probably come out after
Avengers end game and it will probably
give us a little bit more info because
we will have known what happens in
Avengers end game so the next trailer
probably won't come until after Avengers
end game and that will be a full trailer
although this trailer is long and really
really awesome it's still a teaser
trailer so the next one should be a full
trailer and then we have the last scene
which is funny and ironic because we
have flash just praising spider-man
saying how much he loves him and then he
makes fun of Peter Parker and of course
they're the same person so that's it for
my full breakdown of the very first
spider-man far from home teaser trailer
let me know how awesome you thought it
was and let me
your favorite part of the trailer in the
comments down below and just a heads up
I'm giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet if you'd like to enter the
giveaway for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero and be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on everything
related to spider-man far from home
Avengers in game and all things Marvel
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]